all right we have more MORTAL KOMBAT 11
to talk about so let's let's talk about
it you know I love me some Mortal Kombat
[Music]
Mortal Kombat 11 aftermath so Mortal
Kombat 11 aftermath is the that's right
cleverly titled
the aftermath the Mortal Kombat 11 after
the events of Mortal Kombat 11 with
spoilers from Mortal Kombat 11 if you
haven't played through the story
entirely
Liu Kang beats the time tight and cronic
Assoc goes down he's like alright I'm a
god now so I can remake existence as I
see fit but now and aftermath Shang soon
comes to him and he's like no you're
gonna do my song we need to go questing
so you don't doom us all trust me I'm
shakes him so now you have a few more
chapters of Mortal Kombat 11 to
playthrough in which you have to go
questing with Shang Tsung and the DLC
characters come into the story DLC
characters that aren't exclusive to
Mortal Kombat aftermath but we've seen
before like sandeul's a huge part of the
story I love me some more Sindel I just
love me some evil mill folk and I said
so we have more story to play through
more characters let's just unpack it so
logistically the story is more of what
you would expect from NetherRealm
Studios telling a Mortal Kombat story I
mean the story is it's interesting it's
fun they keep it engaging though I feel
like there are spoilers in this story
from the DLC characters endings like
endings you've already seen it would
have been more intriguing if those
reveals hadn't come out I was like
that's I already know though I know
you're trying to keep it like who's evil
who's good I already know because I beat
Mortal Kombat 11 with the DLC characters
that were already out before aftermaths
expansion but the story is great the
graphics are [ __ ] up good because
we've already seen that Mortal Kombat 11
just ed Boone and his team they've
always been the tip of the spear of epic
storytelling in fighting games from the
original Mortal Kombat 2 now in Mortal
Kombat even with the injustice games so
this story provides a few more chapters
of Mortal Kombat intrigue and
storytelling and that's fun stuff though
it's only a few more chapters we'll get
into that as four characters we get
three more DLC characters Shiva
Fujin and Robocop because movie
crossovers they're always fun it's funny
enough with Fujin I'm pretty sure
there's a Mortal Kombat mythologies
throwback shout out when fujian fights
noob saibot I believe it was when I was
playing the story they say something
about
bihaan the original sub-zero who becomes
noob saibot fighting fujian in his
temple it was like there's that a mortal
kombat mythology sub-zero throwback good
that's cool I mean the game is
unplayable it's brutal but as cool
there's also a dialogue between Shiva
and Baraka that talks about Onaga it's
always neat when Mortal Kombat dialogue
throws to other mythology and you're
like are you bringing that into the next
game is that a foreshadow but as for the
three characters in terms of playability
for me Fujin was my personal favorite it
just has some interesting move sets and
combos that actually they speak well to
the way I play though none of the three
are actually as good as some of the
three DLC characters that I can pick
from that they've already come out with
like thinking of three other DLC
characters off the top of my head
spawn Joker and perfection all better
than the three DLC characters that are
in Mortal Kombat aftermath for me just
leads me to think like if you're gonna
roll out three DLC characters in this
expansion that's 40 bucks make one of
them one of the best characters in
Mortal Kombat xi how do they suck or
anything but are any of them as good as
spawn no I like the novelty of Robocop
but once the novelty wears out I'm then
met with that realization that if you're
a cyborg in Mortal Kombat 11 I just
don't play well as you characters with
cybernetic enhancements fine
cyborgs nope it's funny because in some
of the other MK games the cyborgs they
we're great Mortal Kombat 11 I do not
play well with cyborgs we don't just get
a few new chapters of story we don't
just get three new DLC characters no we
get some new stages some new stage
fatalities and some friendships we get a
couple classic stages like the soul
chamber the Deadpool not Deadpool as in
Deadpool but Deadpool as in Deadpool
though that'd be pretty sweet to have
Deadpool in this game probably have to
pay out the ass for the licensing but
I'm just saying but as we can't get
Deadpool the person we have Deadpool the
stage and that's also a stage fatality
classic oh this time they go up on a
hook and they get lowered into the acid
Terminator does not give us thumbs up
it's kind of sad about that which is
funny though a terminator goes into the
acid I'm like well I I don't think he's
strictly speaking terminated I think he
can still be a problem for you but a
couple of stages that were already in
Mortal Kombat 11 they now have stage
fatalities added to them which is pretty
sweet but only three stage fatalities
and we get food
friendships are arguably my favorite
thing about all of this the friendships
are a blast just fun going through the
characters seeing what the friendships
are what they bring to it whether the
friendships are throwback to their mk2
friendships a rift on the powers they
have or a solid end screen where you can
appreciate the sexy evil that is epic
screaming milf the friendships are
quirky they're fun and I just had a
blast the friendship so it was important
to note that the new stages stage
fatalities and friendships those were
all a free patch those aren't even part
of the $40 price tag from Mortal Kombat
11 aftermath which is important to note
because in the end the whole question is
is this DLC worth 40 bucks and strictly
speaking what you get for 40 bucks is a
few new chapters of story which you can
YouTube at this point I'm sure and I do
mean a few in terms of length the Mortal
Kombat 11 aftermath story is less than
half as long as the Mortal Kombat 11
story and three new DLC characters 40
bucks I don't know about that that seems
a little steep I mean at this point the
entirety of Mortal Kombat 11 if you've
kept up on it and got it as it's come
out DLC and all it's about as much as
what Marvel vs. Capcom 2 you can get
that on eBay for the same price maybe
it's apples to oranges the retro game
collector and me sizes that up and I go
okay price point what's worth it what's
what's more honestly speaking I know DLC
is always overpriced and it's always
obnoxious but Mortal Kombat 11 aftermath
is $20 DLC that costs 40 bucks 15 to $20
DLC I'll say 20 if it's $5 per character
and $5 for the news story
maybe they'll roll out more characters
as time goes on and make the $40 price
tag more worth it but as I stand right
now I have to judge Mortal Kombat 11
aftermath for what we have right now and
right now it is 15 to 20 dollar DLC that
costs 40 bucks I'm actually leaning more
towards 15 bucks in 20 bucks I'm sure
there are skins that I have now because
I purchased the DLC but look price point
is subjective what's worth it is
subjective and skins just aren't worth
it for me at no point am I gonna be like
I'll have those skins [ __ ] 40 bucks
it is no it's not gonna happen like
skins are fun to unlock but I'm not
buying that [ __ ] no way at no point no
way shape or form am I gonna be like
alright well since I have those skins
just totally
worth 40 bucks now which means Mortal
Kombat 11 aftermath it's worth buying at
sale price and now school I'd like to
thank the sponsor of this video this
video is brought to you by rake on rake
on earbuds are those slick stylish true
wireless earbuds that started about half
the price of other premium wireless
earbuds on the market and they sound
great their everyday e25 earbuds offer 6
hours of playtime seamless bluetooth
pairing more bass and a more compact
design that gives you a nice noise
isolating fit and bonus it comes in a
variety of new phone colors unlike some
of your other wireless options Raycom
earbuds are stylish they're discreet no
dangling wires or stems and if you still
have Quarantine hair boom even more
discreet i've always said that my rake
on earbuds are my workout buds totally
true but then quarantine laziness it got
me I gotta get back on track with that
but until I do they're still great for
just listening to music sitting back
relaxing and they're great for this
video conference calls those video
hangouts that your friends insist on
doing on a consistent basis during
quarantine that are really hard to find
an excuse to get out of them so if you
gotta log in be stylish while doing it
so click the link below to get yourself
15% off your order and thank you once
again to rikon for sponsoring this video
it really helps me out a lot I really do
appreciate it alright so Mortal Kombat
11 aftermath have you played it what do
you think about it is it worth the 40
bucks for you or are you thinking about
the 20 bucks I'll get it when it's 20
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]